bei den grünen ist der machtkampf
ausgebrochen nachdem wir nun ein jahr
lang gehört haben wie gut sich partei
und fraktion wie gut sich reales und
linke verstehen wird nun gekämpft und
zwar um den fraktionsvorsitz im
bundestag
cem özdemir und kirsten kappa gonther
fordern die jetzigen
fraktionsvorsitzenden katrin göring
eckardt und anton hofreiter heraus am 24
september wird gewählt und bis dahin
laufen viele gespräche werben die vier
kandidaten jeweils für sich
wie stehen nun die chancen gegen die
jetzigen amtsinhaber spricht dass viele
in der fraktion nicht so zufrieden sind
wie sie derzeit die dinge hand haben
manche meinen es gäbe zu wenig debatten
andere vermissen die führungsqualitäten
und dritte sagen dass doch etwas mehr
glanz auf die fraktion fallen könnte
derzeit machen vor allem die
parteivorsitzenden baerbock und harbeck
die schlagzeilen
[Applaus]
allerdings sieht es meines erachtens
trotzdem nicht sonderlich gut aus für
die herausforderer was vor allem daran
liegt dass cem özdemir bei der partei
und in der fraktion insbesondere bei den
linken sehr umstritten ist das lag
einerseits an seinen positionen so ist
er sehr viel unkritischer als viele in
der fraktion und partei was
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr angeht
unvergessen seine sätze darüber dass man
mit yoga matten in der hand keinen krieg
gegen den as gewinnen kann
außerdem erinnern sich viele an den zoff
und zank mit simone peter zu der zeit
als beide die partei führten viele
frauen verdächtigen ihn also frauen
klein zu machen und an die seite zu
drängen
schließlich würde es wenn die beiden
tatsächlich die wahl gewinnen würden an
jemandem fehlen der die klima und öko
themen besetzen kann
das macht derzeit ziemlich erfolgreich
anton hofreiter aber weder
kirchenkabarett sonntag noch cem özdemir
haben einen öko profil kirchenkabarett
gonther ist außerdem sehr unbekannt sie
sitzt erst zwei jahre im bundestag
mark ist dort wenn überhaupt durch
gesundheitsthemen aufgefallen
man wusste gar nicht dass sie derartige
ambitionen überhaupt hat und deswegen
glauben auch viele linke in der fraktion
dass sie nicht in der lage sein wird
gegen cem özdemir linke themen überhaupt
nach vorne zu bringen aber bis zum 24
september ist noch etwas zeit es kommt
sehr auch darauf an wie sich die dynamik
bis dahin entwickelt die fraktion hat
sich jedenfalls fest vorgenommen diesen
machtkampf er auszutragen man hofft doch
so gut es irgendwie geht das bild von
geschlossenheit und harmonie zu wahren
[Musik]